engage with anytime soon."
And of course, we're talking about drones, right,
a technology that's not only unpopular in the West
but one that has become a very, very unpleasant
fact of life for many living in poor countries,
especially those engaged in conflict.
So why are we doing this?
Well, we chose to do this one
not because it's easy,
but because it can have amazing impact.
Imagine one billion people being connected
to physical goods in the same way
that mobile telecommunications connected them
to information.
Imagine if the next big network we built in the world
was a network for the transportation of matter.
In the developing world, we would hope
to reach millions of people with better vaccines,
reach them with better medication.
It would give us an unfair advantage against battling
HIV/AIDS, tuberculosis and other epidemics.
Over time, we would hope it would become
a new platform for economic transactions,
lifting millions of people out of poverty.
In the developed world and the emerging world,
we would hope it would become a new mode
of transportation that could help make our cities
more livable.
So for those that still believe that this is science fiction,
I firmly say to you that it is not.
We do need to engage, though,
in social fiction to make it happen.
Thank you.
(Applause)